hallo
herzlich willkommen in weiter trocken
meldet ich war vor kurzem im urlaub in
der türkei
und das erste was ich in der türkei
immer mache ist obst und gemüse kaufen
und da war ich dann auf dem markt und
habe mir natürlich ganz frische feigen
gekauft die falken der türkei sind ganz
besonders lecker ich kenne aber auch gar
keinen beiden von anderen ländern
ich glaube wenn der teig alessa sommer
ist wird bleiben auch aus kalifornien
oder australien und so geliefert und die
feigen muss man natürlich in der türkei
auch mal probiert haben das heißt jeder
der dort mal in urlaub ist muss auf
jeden fall mal auf den markt um frische
feigen probieren
ich habe jetzt hier in deutschland die
feigen in einem türkischen supermarkt
gefunden
da gibt es die meistens oder auch in
großen supermärkten bei uns gibt es die
auch beim globus der hat da so eine
internationale ecke oder so eine
exotische ecke und da gibt es dann
zusammen wie mango und ingwer fein
granatapfel und aus diesen feigen wollte
jetzt heute ein leckeres rezept machen
aber bevor ich euch dieses rezept zahl
wie möchte ich einfach mal kurz aus über
die feige erzählen so sieht sie aus und
hat eine schöne dunkle farbe beiden
feigen erkennt ihr daran dass sie bei
trug leicht nachgeben diese hier ist
jetzt schon etwas über alt weil ich
ihren auch schon zwei tage hier im
kühlschrank hatte und im inneren
so aus im innern könnt ihr diese tolle
körnung hier
und im streng genommen sind auch dass
hier die früchte also nicht die
komplette besonderen stein gelungen
botanisch gesehen sind es darin die
gelben teile die fürchten weil sie nicht
nur extrem lecker sondern auch sehr
gesund also sich schnecken es süß aber
nicht zu süß deswegen kann man sie auch
ganz gut als vorspeise mit etwas butter
oder sauce servieren und natürlich auch
zum dessert und feigen sind total gesund
weil sie viel magnesium enthalten viel
einzelnen fonds frau und calcium und
vitamin a und ich werde jetzt aus diesen
feigen heute einen marmeladen trocken
natürlich kann man daraus auch die tat
machen oder ganz viele andere rezepte
aber ich habe mich jetzt einfach für die
formulare entschieden weil ich auch mit
der marmelade später weiter arbeiten
kann und die zum beispiel nicht nur aufs
brot stehen kann sondern auch zu einer
vorspeise termin kann oder einfach zu
einem käseteller ich werde ich jetzt
einfach mal zeigen wie ich die marmelade
mache das ganze ist in etwa 10 minuten
gemacht natürlich mit wartezeit aber
arbeitszeit hat man etwa zehn minuten
und ich bin jetzt einfach sagen ich zeig
euch die zutaten und dann geht's los
ich habe jetzt hier frische feigen und
zwar sind es 800 gramm und dafür habe
ich jetzt zucker genommen gelierzucker
das ist so ein drei plus eins zucker das
heißt ich habe drei teile früchte und
einen teils zucker also habe ich jetzt
hier knapp 250 gramm genommen ich wollte
es nicht ganz die drei teile ausschöpfen
oder den einen teil ausschöpfen und hier
habe ich noch den saft einer halben
zitrone darf sofort eine bio zitrone
die feierliches waffen und dann geht es
gleich weiter
zuerst könnt ihr hier oben den
stielansatz entfernen und dann die
feigen mit einem scharfen messer
halbieren unten nehmen wir dann noch den
strunk ansatz heraus und können dann die
feigen hälften in kleine würfel
schneiden
bei mir sind die würfel zu etwa 1 cm
groß ihr könnt sie auch größer oder
kleiner schneiden und einfach alle fein
würfeln
samira schmecken die feigen übrigens
sehr gut deswegen hat es auch immer mal
wieder feigen geklaut diese kommen dann
alle zusammen in einen großen topf und
werden dann mit dem zucker abgedeckt da
gibt ihr auch direkt den kompletten
zucker mit rein verrührt das ganze ganz
kurz mit einem kochlöffel und lasst es
dann mit geschlossenem deckel für etwa
zwei stunden stehen damit die
flüssigkeit aus den feigen herauskommt
und wir später die marmelade schön
einkommen können
nach zwei stunden könnt ihr deutlich
sehen die flüssigkeit ist rausgekommen
der zucker hat sich aufgelöst
ich habe mir jetzt bereits meine zwei
marmeladengläser zurechtgelegt einmal
ein schraubglas und einmal ein
einmachglas
und jetzt wird die marmelade auf dem
herd für etwa vier minuten gekocht und
das ganze unter ständigem rühren
sobald die marmelade aufgekocht ist
müsst ihr sie wie gesagt vier minuten
lang kochen lassen und dann kommt noch
der zitronensaft mit hinzu das ganze
wird dann noch einmal kurz verrührt und
dann könnt ihr die marmelade bereits in
die gläser abfüllen
denn dann ist sie auch schon fertig bei
mir waren das jetzt ein großes und ein
kleines glas es sind ungefähr zwei
mittlere gläser werte so haben möchtet
sobald die marmelade dann abgekühlt ist
ist sie auch schon bereit und ihr könnt
sie auf euer brot streichen
ich finde marmelade nicht nur optisch
sehr schön sondern auch geschmacklich
sehr lecker aufgebrochen könnt ihr sie
dann im kühlschrank aufbewahren
und wenn ihr sie nicht aufgebrochen habt
könnt ihr es ja auch im vorratsschrank
lagern
praktisch so ein grundrezept beraten mit
diesem dreier gruppe
und diese keilten werden wahrscheinlich
andere länder verkauft haben
aber ich glaube
van bommel herstellt wir können doch
ganz fertig sein und auch viele gewählte
mit einem allerdings möchte und ich
hoffe dass sich dieses kleine und
schnelle rezept gefallen und freue mich
einfach auf die nächsten mal
das verträgt steige ich euch trotz
dieses dieser mailin so taten auch
manager ausgelegt
welt.de und wir sehen zum nächsten mal
wieder und freue mich auf eure
kommentare